[Music]
it is 6 43 and it is time to talk about
a place that i
have loved talking about but i still
haven't gone to monica i know
oh i drive by like i drive by the smith
center almost every day and i've yet to
go inside and hopefully that can change
moving forward here let me tell you
something myron martin has heard that
he's going to do
for you what he did for me he has trust
me i've heard it from my room before oh
yeah
i know well thank you john and happy
monday to you hey folks so from the very
beginning the smith center was
envisioned as a world-class performing
arts center that would develop and
present
the best brightest and bro i mean just
everything i can tell you ladies and
gentlemen
this place is unbelievable i don't even
need prompter to tell me that
i've been there the first show that i
saw there was hamilton
and it took my breath away i cannot wait
to talk to myron martin because they
have been closed for a whole year the
pandemic shut them down and really hurt
them
but right now they're coming back so
this is a great story a great interview
myron martin how
are you mr ceo on the comeback
hello monica jackson so nice to see you
hey it is nice to see you too and
congratulations i was so
happy to hear that the schedule is
online
broadway is coming back first of all
tell me how you guys are doing
and how is the comeback going because i
know there's a lot of preparation that
goes into this
you know we've been closed for a year
it'll be 18 months
before we reopen yeah and we've never
worked harder
uh preparing for the reopening making
sure that we are
instituting all kinds of new safety
measures so that
when we open we open with gusto and we
bring all of our friends and neighbors
back to see great shows
yeah and you're gonna do it martin i i
have absolutely
no doubt about that okay so i was just
telling john i saw hamilton
and i remember i'm not a musical kind of
girl i'll be honest with everybody i
don't like musicals
i had never planned on seeing it myron
martin says monica
this is going to be your first time at
the smith center you have got to come
see hamilton
i go see hamilton i almost fainted i'm
not even kidding
it was so breathtaking it was so amazing
martin i remember telling you
it was the best history lesson i've ever
had and i hate
history not only do you have that show
coming but you have like five
other shows six other shows coming back
well yeah so we have we have six big
shows coming this season uh starting
with cats
you know one of the great andrew lloyd
webber shows
yeah first time ever at the smith center
so
so that opens our broadway season an
officer and a gentleman remember the
movie
it is now a broadway show
here before it goes to broadway
and of course we always like to do a
holiday show around the thanksgiving
period and we were able to get
a christmas carol a beautiful show that
they did just a year or two ago
in new york which is nice my fair lady
the classic
uh will be making it smith center debut
if you can believe that
and then two new shows a band's visit uh
that won
so many tony awards ten of them ten
pony awards and then we close out this
season with
tootsie i don't think i have to
set up tootsie no
and you're right monica we have
announced that the following
season will include the return of
hamilton
[Laughter]
i cannot wait and you know myron let our
folks know because again you know we
need to help you guys get back on your
feet
and you know let's be honest money has
to be part of
the equation how can people get involved
in terms of getting their passes for the
year how does all that stuff work
yes so listen go to the smith center dot
com there are lots of ways you can help
there's a way that if you're interested
in season tickets you can
register your interest we have a waiting
list for broadway season tickets but
there's a place for you to get in line
there and and get your name on the list
there are also ways that you can help
and monica i have to tell you this
community has come out to support
the smith center in ways i can't even
describe nice
yeah donated their tickets for
cancelled shows back to us as a way of
helping pay
our bills our staff
most of whom have been furloughed and
laid off are standing by and they can't
wait to come back and greet all of our
guests once again
well i can't wait for you guys to come
back too but myron
a lot of people still don't know there
is also another reason to come
and just hang out at the smith center i
know you know what i'm talking about
tell everybody about that because again
i don't think most people know it exists
well so so listen uh branford marsalis
called
mudrun's
jazz room in america it is a place where
you go and get some light bites and a
drink
and you listen to your favorite
musicians i mean
local music people like clint holmes
well i'm not going to go down my list of
frank maria
and all of our good friend lon bronson
uh
i'll see now i've started yeah yeah
brewing artists to come to las vegas
just to play at the smith center
uh 220 seats it's an intimate space it's
like
your favorite musicians in your living
room
it's gorgeous and yes myron's cabaret
jazz will be reopening this fall as well
as and and reynolds hall we've not
announced any of our concerts or other
things that aren't broadway yet
but believe me monica there's something
for everybody at the smith center
and we can't wait to see our friends and
neighbors again well hey
we can't wait to see you and again myron
i really i'm so happy for you guys there
because i know
how hard you've worked you and your team
over there the folks behind the scenes
i know a lot of those folks actually
worked with some of those folks
and i know it's been a labor of love for
you so thank you so much tell everybody
how they can reach out to the smith
center for tickets passes donations
whatever they need
you bet the smithcenter.com the
smithcenter.com you can find everything
you need there and like i say we can't
wait to see you
all right any messages for john langler
who has yet to be
a guest at the smith center let's just
put him on front right now
be kind meyer and be kind yeah listen
john
i i would pick on you but but monica is
the person
who had said every time i saw her i
still haven't been there
i'm coming i still haven't been there
well guess what john now it's your turn
well we're gonna find the show that that
that
knocks you out that makes you want to
come back over and over again i'm ready
i'm ready let's do it all right
very good thank you myron again so nice
to see you my friend and uh
congratulations to you and your team
over there
all right guys thanks so much thanks
monica all right take care folks hey and
don't forget catch my mlj show facebook
live
a monday through friday at 7 p.m of
course we're gonna replay this and
make sure you get all the information
you need to help our folks over at the
smith center
okay sherry you've been here longer than
i have here in las vegas
so tell me you've been over to the
smithsonian oh yeah many many times
and the cabaret lounge and myron's
cabaret lounge
it's fantastic and i'm gonna say as much
as i want john to have that experience
yeah i'm not giving up my seat so sorry
john you'll just have to get your own
ticket
figure out how to get over there leave
that alone
we'll figure it out